so you got a pitch feeding reaction for
me yes sir i do we are going to watch
the suicide squad pitch meeting today
but waiting for this one did come out a
couple days ago but hey we're here now
guys subscribe to ryan george's solo
channel if you haven't done so already
and yeah subscribe to scream rat it's a
good channel
he's carrying the whole channel
in a little bit
let's get into this
[Music]
so you have a movie for me yes sir i do
so you remember suicide squad from 2016.
oh yeah that movie that i hired people
to kind of chop up and then everybody
blamed the director for how much they
hated it
that has a nice ring to it actually
right yeah yeah yeah suicide squad the
oh you want to put at the beginning yeah
that's good too great so is this like a
sequel or a reboot or a soft reboot yes
fantastic yeah we're gonna take some of
the characters from the first movie
played by the same actors oh very fun
and some new ones too oh yeah there's
gonna be a bunch of new characters
there's gonna be one named blackguard
and i thought we could get pete davidson
to play him people love pete davidson
that's going to be a fun character and
his face is going to explode almost
immediately oh my god i also thought we
could get nathan and people like that
too oh no he's great what's he going to
do die almost immediately okay wow
michael rooker he'd be great to play one
of these guys to do what die almost
immediately okay what is happening
there's gonna be a whole suicide squad
team at the beginning of the movie that
just kind of gets wiped out as a
distraction okay so like lesser known
characters and you'll have more known
characters in the movie too like captain
boomerang yeah he's in the movie so
what's he gonna do die almost
immediately oh my god okay does anyone
not die immediately is the movie five
minutes long we want to start the movie
by sending the message that anyone can
die at any time right ah that's just
like in real life yeah so anyway out of
that first team there's rick flag
what about on the main team who do we
have on there well there's this one guy
right and he's like an amazing shooter
and he's like a reluctant leader and his
main motivation is his daughter yeah
dead shot
shot he was in the last movie there's a
guy called bloodsport oh did you guys
know that the original concept art was
showing that it was supposed to be
deathstroke who i think james go was
originally writing for there's actual
concept art for it it's pretty crazy
stuff but yeah when you break down the
nuts and bolts it's a very similar type
of setup backstory i don't know what to
believe some people say that yeah
deadshot was supposed to be in it but
then andre selva was cast to replace him
but then they're like no we might want
will smith to come back later so have it
or someone play a different character
but then i'm like what about the
deathstroke concept i don't know what's
real it's a good thing they all have the
same back stories that okay and there's
this other predatory animal character
that eats humans killer croc yeah i know
no this is king shark ah i should stop
trying to predict things i guess you're
not particularly good at it cern we also
have this other character who shoots
polka dots and another one who controls
rats working for pest control is tight
no her name is rat catcher too and she
can like control rats with her mind and
then there's peacemaker who's like
bloodsport except he murders in the name
of peace who were you thinking for that
role i was thinking maybe john cena oh
you know what i can't see him in that
role
because of his catchphrase i understand
the joke sir i just hate it that's fair
so anyway pretty much all these
characters
okay so i imagine they're each gonna
have a tattoo on their forehead
explaining that no
once in a while one of them will stop
and explain their past to the other
characters which i think you'll agree is
a little more subtle i guess and so yeah
amanda waller implants bombs into all
these people's necks which is the whole
premise of the thing sure and so she
sends them all to this island laboratory
to destroy this experiment called
project starfish so what kind of stuff
does the squad get up to on this island
well first of all they need to go save
rick flag because it seems like he's
been captured okay so peacemaker and
bloodsport they have this kind of
competition where they go through this
camp but just kill people in horrific
ways just extremely bloody and graphic
oh so we're like talking like an r
rating here yeah because this way we get
to see some brains and spinal cords and
say stuff like 69 and splooge 69 that's
the funny number yeah it is and the
other stuff is gross yeah it is
this very that rick flag is in and it
turns out the camp was full of good guys
he wasn't even captured whoops whoopsie
and so rick flag didn't hear any of the
commotion no he didn't hear the people
screaming or exploding or the guard
tower collapsing right next to him how
did he not hear any of that well he was
in intent
and so we're also going to meet up oh
that is brilliant both times i've seen
it and for some reason my mind never
actually went there i was so invested in
how cool the scene is and how funny the
reveal is that i never actually thought
about the very obvious gap in logic of
how did none of them hear what was going
on the whole time there's so much noise
happening at least after this exploding
bullet like come on because i heard like
cosmonaut variety hour criticized that
scene for kind of pulling him out
because they're supposed to be stealthy
but they're making a whole bunch of
noise and all that like okay yeah i can
see that that's really bothering me but
that that is a solid point right there
that's a very solid point and so we're
also gonna meet up with harley quinn and
what's she up to we'll see since she's
the most popular character i figured she
should get her own solo movie well she
already got her own movie yeah well
she's gonna get another one inside of
this one that makes sense so she has
this whole big side quest and even a
love interest and she ends up being
captured by these military people and
she's being tortured for info that's
painful it sure is sir but then she
pretends to be unconscious and so she
strangles this guy with her legs when
his back is turned well well thank god
he took a break with his back turn while
still within her reach or that plan
wouldn't have worked at all it worked
out pretty great so then she takes out a
little pressure
crazy martial arts and stuff harley
quinn is better at hand-to-hand combat
than a full squad of trained military
people yes no further questions so
eventually they get their hands on this
bad guy crazy that is so true because
it's funny when you look back at the
first suicide squad movie that was
something that a lot of people were
going what
harley quinn's like really great at
martial arts and yet when this one rolls
around no not even myself questions
exactly
yeah i accept it as part of her
character but even like the animated
property she's really good at martial
arts but i remember it like was throwing
people for a loop quite a bit of like
how is she so good at martial arts yeah
yeah especially because we don't see any
transition between her going from being
dr quinzel to harley quinn yeah she has
like a gymnast background but that's not
really explored doesn't really mean
you're an expert martial artist
so eventually they get their hands on
this bad guy called the thinker who's
been running the starfish experiment for
like 30 years okay and so obviously
that's going to lead into like the third
act where they have a big situation to
deal with oh i see where you're going
with this so what color is the sky beam
going to be i was kind of thinking maybe
we don't do a sky beam well we usually
do a sky beam yeah but i was thinking we
could do more of like a giant hive mine
starfish from outer space getting eaten
by millions of rats and one of the main
characters pierces its eye with a
javelin and all the rats go in there
we usually do a skybridge yeah i know
okay so anyway it turns out that amanda
told peacemaker to get this hard drive
that proves that the government's been
funding the whole starfish thing oh but
rick flagg doesn't think that's very
nice so they get in a fight and
peacemaker kills rick flags very rude
and then ratcatcher 2 gets the hard
drive so peacemaker wants to kill her
it's gonna be hard for her to get out of
that situation exactly it's gonna be
super easy
oh really yes because of an explosion
blood sports gonna fall through multiple
stories i love that moment
i don't care anyone says save the day
without injury oh that is convenient it
sure is sir then we're gonna have a
scene where king shark falls from a
building and gets shot point blank with
a bunch of machine guns but his skin's
so tough it doesn't hurt him at all very
cool how'd they inject the bomb into his
neck unclear and so this explosion is
lost oh god
what a great call that is good yeah
because i'm not even 100 clear on what
the rules are i was like the bullets
just seem to bounce off this guy unless
you get like way way way many of them so
what do they have to do like in a just
an industrially thick needle or
something i don't know that's a great
question because yeah the bullets pounce
off him but those like weird sea
creatures in the aquatic tank were able
to bite into and that's where all his
wounds were from and what he was
bleeding from yeah maybe they needed one
made out of a tooth lack of rules here
so that is a that's a great question
that is solid so this explosion is also
going to set this giant hive mind
starfish free uh-oh and so this thing
shoots out little starfish that attach
to people's faces and that's how it does
its hive mind thing exactly so i guess
the good guys need to keep their faces
covered for the whole fight huh no they
just do it like once each and that does
this
is
very true just give up afterwards okay
so this hive mind is kind of a big moral
dilemma to tackle huh like do you kill
these people that are innocent but
they're being mind controlled by an
alien oh no we're gonna have a little
line explaining that they're corpses
under the starfish so they're already
dead oh okay thank god so we don't have
a sky beam but we do have a faceless
soulless army well we gotta do some of
the classics yeah we do i will say
though within the faceless mindless army
that when you do get to the starro
speech a few lines about how he was just
happy floating in space that is very
effective and they all have colorful
faces yes and i like the action scene
i was just making jokes here but it
reminded me so much of like invasion of
the body statures that uh i was able to
see it for for that light more than
anything else so then ratcatcher 2
summons millions of rats to attack this
starfish seems like maybe she could have
solved a lot of the movie's problems all
on her own yeah well this is the climax
of the movie so this is really when they
use the full extent of their powers
that's fair and so yeah then harley
quinn pierces the eye of the giant
starfish with a javelin and that takes
care of that and so they hadn't fired
bullets at the giant starfish eye they
did but only the javelin does any damage
what yes
wait why are knives so much stronger
while your blades is so much stronger
maybe than bullets in this universe
maybe it's the length advantage maybe
you need just a really long bullet
that's such a great question i think
there's ever a shot of them shooting the
eye yeah i feel like there's one shot
where you got all the soldiers shooting
upwards and you can see little you know
little pops of smoke or whatever where
the bullets are hitting but yeah i don't
know i i guess in the moment of my you
know suspension of disbelief i was like
maybe they're just bouncing off i don't
know
it's a great question man i think though
that they do kind of put a bit of a
fantasy almost our theory and not that
heavy but there is something that feels
a little bit fantastical about the
javelin it's magic's been building to
this moment yeah it was it was
journeying here to be the crucial key in
turning the fight because when she is
fighting the soldiers it seems like just
like one little hit even for coming from
the side can just like destroy them so i
don't know special javelin i don't know
much about the character journal i know
how special that javelin really is
and so then as starrow is dying he's
like i was happy floating in space
looking at the stars hey excuse me did
you just make me feel bad for a giant
alien starfish with a single line i did
wow
wow wow and so yeah that's about it what
do you think oh it sounds like a lot of
fun you know i think it's gonna perform
great at the box office me too sir so
long as there's not some kind of
seemingly unending worldwide event that
causes hesitancy and people going to the
theaters and also completely changes the
way we release movies to streaming
why would you say that
[Music]
hey everybody ryan here that's me thanks
for watching the video and if you liked
it feel free to click the like button
and the subscribe button and all that
already did it in advance you can also
leave a comment down below letting me
know what other movies you want to see
pictures for they're also like hundreds
of dances or waltz
the room as always check back soon for a
new one bye bye bye
man those variations in reaction
delivery fro as the producer were were
top notch in this one man another killer
pitch meeting i i think i've only maybe
seen one pitch meeting that i was like
that was all right i think it was uh
soul was the only one where i was like
that was all right but every other one
brilliant they're all like pitch perfect
puns are tight guys subscribe to pitch
speedy screen rant if you haven't done
so already subscribe to ryan george's
channel you can subscribe to us thank
you brian george for putting this
brilliant video together hit that like
button go watch suicide squad if you
haven't theaters do it in the theaters
last but not least let's do a p
pandemic jones pj you would be the
perfect person to join a suicide squad
think about it if they really need
someone part of the suicide squad
mission what better than having a guy
named pandemic jones a dude who has the
osmosis ability to be able to start a
pandemic with just enough concentration
and willpower pandemic jones you are the
next person on the list part of the
d-less category of james gunn characters
but you will rise to being a seed sealer
it's your fate with such a name like
that the man who can single-handedly
start appending and many of you guys
don't even know this he single-handedly
started the pandemic we are currently in
now and we're the only ones who haven't
judged him so guys i'm going to be
putting out his email his mailing
address if you really want to hit him up
and have a conversation with him about
everything that we're in right now
because he is solely responsible for all
of that very knowledgeable south park
was making fun of him so pandemic jones
thank you for being part of our patreon
page you keep doing what you're doing
[Music]